MASSIVE CROWD, MASSIVE RALLY,
THIS TIME IN RIO RANCHO,
NEW MEXICO.
WE BRING IN OUR NEW COLLEAGUE,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS.
YOU DID A JOB THAT, FOR ME,
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE.
I COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT
PROBABLY GOING
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI ON THEM,
WHICH IS A COMPLIMENT.
I LIKE THAT.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THIS IS
NOW -- YOU DEALT WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AGENDA ADVANCED
BY A CORRUPT MEDIA, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIES, BREATHLESS
HYSTERICAL REPORTING, AND IT'S
ALWAYS WRONG.
THEY GOT THE WHOLE THING WRONG.
WE GOT EIGHT BREAKOUT
A LITTLE TALK SHOW HOST ON TV
FIGURED IT OUT WHEN THEY DIDN'T.
WE DIDN'T FOLLOW THE MOB, AND AS
A RESULT, WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THE TRUTH TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND IT IS GETTING
CONFIRMED MORE AND MORE EVERY
DAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FIRST, SEAN, I THINK HE WOULD
HAVE DONE GREAT IN MY JOB AND I
DON'T THINK THE MEDIA WOULD HAVE
LIKED YOU VERY MUCH BECAUSE I
THINK YOU WOULD HAVE EMBARRASSED
THEM ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Hannity: YOU HAVE THE
PATIENCE -- AND THEN THEY
DOUBTED YOU ARE BAKED FRIES.
YOU BRING THE EMPIRES AND SAY
THAT YOU BAKE THEM, THEY STILL
SAY, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU BAKED
THEM.
>> I THINK IT SHOWS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH THE MEDIA
IS, THEY WANT TO QUESTION
EVERYONE'S CREDIBILITY WHEN THE
WHOLE WORLD IS STARTING THEIRS.
THE AGENDAS OF OBSTRUCTION THEY
HAVE AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
THEY TRY TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY HATE THAT
HE WON IN 2016, DEDICATED THAT
HE WAS ABLE TO START DELIVERING
ON ALL THE THINGS HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO, INCLUDING A
CONSERVATIVE COURT.
THE IDEA THAT HE IS BUILDING,
NOT JUST CRAVINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING, THEY'RE TAKING PLACE
UNDER THIS TERM, BUT HE IS
BUILDING A LEGACY THAT WILL LIVE
ON LONG AFTER HE IS NO LONGER
PRESIDENT, THROUGH THE NOMINEES
AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED TO COURTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, INCLUDING TWO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T BEAT HIM, THAT THEY
ARE GOING AFTER EVERYONE AROUND
HIM, EVERYONE ASSOCIATED WITH
HIM, AND THEY ARE EVEN MAKING
STUFF UP.
IT'S COMPLETELY OUT-OF-CONTROL.
AND AT SOME POINT, THEY HAVE TO
START HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
I THINK IT PRESIDENT'S RIGHT TO
START CALLING FOR SOMETHING TO
BE DONE.
THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE THINGS
APPEAR LESS ACUTE CNM MAKE UP
THIS ABSURD STORY ABOUT A CIA
OPERATIVE.
YOU HAD POLITICAL MAKE UP A
STORY ABOUT THE AIR FORCE
REROUTING PLANES PAID THIS
WEEK YOU HAVE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
GIVE THREE DIFFERENT MAJOR
OUTLETS.
THE ONLY THING THEY HAVE IN
COMMON IS THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
OUT FAKE NOSE, TRYING TO SAY IT
IS TRUE, ALL IN A WAY TO TAKE
THE PRESIDENT DOWN.
>> Hannity: WE HAVE GOT ABOUT
A TWO-MINUTE WARNING ON MOST OF
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO STEP
ON STAGE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR, WHEN HE SAYS LOCKED AND
LOADED, I WOULD TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY IF I WAS A MULLAH IN
IRAN.
SUCCESSFULLY BEAT THE CALIPHATE
BACK IN SYRIA AND ISIS, DID IT
WITH NO BOOTS ON THE GROUND ARE
VERY LIMITED.
SIMILARLY I WOULD NOT EXPECT THE
PRESIDENT TO GET ENTANGLED WITH
IRAN, BUT WITH THAT SAID, I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS PERCENTAGE
IS GOING TO ALLOW IRAN TO MOVE
FORWARD AND DICTATE THE FREE
FLOW OF OIL MARKET PRICES OR
DISRUPT THAT.
IT'S GREAT FOR US.
WE ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
BUT IF EVERY COUNTRY WE DO
BUSINESS WITH, IF THEY NOW ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE IRANIANS, IT'S
NOT GOOD FOR THE WORLD ECONOMY.
THEREFORE, I WOULD EXPECT THE
PRESIDENT, AND I'M HOPING FOR BB
NETANYAHU'S VICTORY.
THIS IS NOW A LINE IN THE SAND.
IT APPEARS THEY ARE NOT ASKING
TO GET HITCHED, IT APPEARS THE
PRESIDENT IS VERY CAPABLE OF
DOING WHAT THEY WANT.
>> ABSOLUTELY, I WOULD NOT TEST
THIS PRESIDENT, MIKE PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
HE IS GOING TO SAY, NOT ON MY
WATCH, HE IS NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE TO BE THE
BULLIES OF THE WORLD, AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR
THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN, LIKE YOU SAID,
THANK GOD THAT WE HAVE BECOME AN
ENERGY INDEPENDENT NATION UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT, BUT WE CANNOT
ALLOW IRAN TO CONTINUE ACTING IN
THE WAY THEY HAVE FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES, THE WAY THEY
CONTINUE TO HURT COUNTRIES
ACROSS THE GLOBE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT, IF I WAS
THEM, I WOULDN'T TEST THIS
PRESIDENT.
I THINK HE HAS PROVEN HIS
ABILITY NOT JUST TO FIGHT BACK,
BUT FIGHT BACK HARDER THAN
ANYTHING THEY THINK IS POSSIBLE.
THE TEAM THAT HE HAS AROUND HIM,
WITH SECRETARY POMPEO AND
OTHERS, MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISION, I KNOW IT WILL BE
ABOUT THIS, MAKING SURE THAT WE
REMAIN ENERGY INDEPENDENT, TWO
THINGS THAT ARE VITAL IMPORTANT
TWO THINKS HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY DO SINCE BECOMING
PRESIDENT.
>> Hannity: THE OTHER ISSUE,
BETWEEN THE MEDIA MOB AND
ALLIES, THERE IS A VERY HEAVY
PRICE THAT I WOULD PAY AS A TALH
PRICE THAT I WOULD PAY AS A TALW
PRICE THAT I WOULD PAY AS A TALS
PRICE THAT I WOULD PAY AS A TAL.
EVERYBODY SEEMS TO THINK IT
TALK SHOW HOST ONLY DOES OPINION
BUT, NO, AS A TALK SHOW HOST, WE
ACTUALLY REPORT NOTES.
I CAN PRODUCE THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF STRAIGHT NEWS COVERAGE WHERE
WE ARE JUST ASKING QUESTIONS.
THERE'S EVENTS UNFOLDING.
THERE IS POOR.
THIS HURRICANES
WE DID THAT.
WE INVESTIGATED INTO THE DEEP
DIVE ON OBAMA.
WE POINTED OUT OBAMA'S FAILED
RECORD AFTER EIGHT YEARS.
NOBODY WOULD DO THAT.
ALSO ON THE DEEP STATE.
FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO
ADMIT 2.5 YEARS LATE, OH, IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT DOSSIER WAS
THERE FROM THE BEGINNING, I'M
LIKE, YEAH, YOU ARE ONLY TWO
YEARS AND 5,000 YEARS LATER
CATCHING UP TO WHERE WE HAVE
BEEN FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT IT IS HURTFUL BECAUSE THAT
IS 99% OF THE MEDIA.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL THEM THE
MALT, BECAUSE THEY HAVE A MOB
MENTALITY.
WHY IS IT SO PERSONAL FOR THEM
AND THIS PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK BECAUSE HE CONTINUES
TO PROVE THEM WRONG.
EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT THEY SAY
THIS PRESIDENT WON'T DO
SOMETHING, HE WON'T SUCCEED, HE
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING ON
IMMIGRATION, HE'LL CRIPPLE THE
ECONOMY, HE WON'T REBUILD THE
MILITARY, HE WON'T CUT TAXES,
EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY SAY HE
WON'T DO IT, HE DOES THAT.
IT MAKES THEM EMBARRASSED, IT
MAKES THEM LOOK LIKE FOOLS, AND
HE CONTINUES TO DO IT.
I THINK THEY ARE STILL MAD THAT
HE WON IN 2016 AND THEY ARE MAD
THAT HE IS WINNING EVERY SINGLE
DAY FOR THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK IT IS INCREDIBLY SAD
THAT THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
WOULD RATHER SEE THE PRESIDENT
FAILED THEN OUR COUNTRY SUCCEED.
I HOPE THAT THEY WILL START TO
LEARN FROM SOME OF THESE MAJOR
MISTAKES THAT HAVE HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS AND START
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
START PUTTING SOME CHECKS AND
BALANCES.
GO BACK TO WHERE WE HAVE A TRUE
EDITORIAL PROCESS WHERE THEY ARE
CHECKING THESE THINGS AND
STORIES ARE JUST BEING PUSHED
OUT IN HOPES THAT THEY CAN PUT
SOMEBODY DOWN BUT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY MAKING SURE THAT THE
STORIES ARE GREAT, THAT THEY ARE
ACCURATE.
LET'S HOPE THAT THEY LEARN